is this good
position
more like this right
oh it was you who made that video i see
okay
[Laughter]
well i think that
mathematicians learn this
stuff at some point
and i learned it at some point
and it's so and then you kind of forget
so you kind of put it in a in a box
somewhere and you put it in the closet
and you kind of put it you classify it
under stuff which you have already
understood
but i think actually uh we don't really
fully understand what what's happening
here let me
recall what
what we're talking about one plus two
and so on and the question is what is
the answer well at first of course you
say there is no answer or the answer is
infinity and we say that because of
because this series is what we
mathematicians call a divergent
it's blowing up you get larger and
larger so there's no sense of being
getting closer to anything so
traditionally what do we do with the
diversion series we just ignore them we
just ignore them we just throw them away
but the question is whether this is the
right approach whether there is actually
something we can say about such a series
which is meaningful in other words can
we assign a value to this series which
is meaningful professor is it not
meaningful to say that it blows up and
goes to infinity is that not meaningful
it is meaningful in the standard context
of such series the way you can think
about this is as follows think of this
okay so we have to resign to the fact
that it is infinite somehow but imagine
this whole series is kind of this huge
lump
but what if there is a way what if there
is sort of a nice
scalpel which will allow us to
surgically remove infinity kind of a bad
infinity out of it
and then keep kind of a finite part then
we would say we will assign that finite
part as the true answer for this
infinite series
now we have to realize that that may not
be possible for any divergent series for
example you could do something like 1
plus 2 plus 3 plus 55 plus 47 plus 6
plus seven plus eight plus something you
know so kind of like a random infinite
series which blows up it will just blow
up it's there's no reason there's no
hope or expectation that there would be
a way to assign a meaningful value to it
but this is a very special series
because you see it's very regular kind
of like one two three four when we are
actually taking the sum of all natural
numbers without any gaps we including
each of them exactly once and what's
interesting is that this kind of sums
pop up all the time in many different
branches of mathematics and quantum
physics mathematicians have thought for
a long time about trying to develop a
theory in which one could actually make
sense of this
and nowadays we have such a theory
and
within that theory we could oftentimes
we can say that it is meaningful to
think of this
or more precisely of that sort of finite
piece after you remove the infinite part
that um sort of a regularized sum
maybe we should
we should make a distinction between
sort of a naive sum when it just blows
up to infinity and a kind of a
regularized sum
where this regular sum actually turns
out to be
this minus one over twelve oh nine minus
one over twelve minus one over twelve so
you see it's very counterintuitive right
because it's actually a negative number
and you are summing up positive numbers
so it certainly is not the result of
summation of these numbers it is
something else but what is it so
mathematicians have developed ways to
come up with this minus one over twelve
and actually the first person to to talk
about this was the great uh
mathematicians leonard euler he was uh
born in basel in switzerland but spent
also a lot of time doing his research in
russia in my home country leonard euler
was a kind of a mathematical outlaw
a kind of a mathematical gangster he was
he did things which were unlawful and
illegitimate and in particular he
allowed himself to manipulate with
infinite serious like this in other
words he was trying to guess what could
be
a possible way to assign a value and in
the process of trying to assign values
to this series and other similar similar
series he actually came up with the
right answers which were justified later
by other mathematicians for example
bernard riemann but that was
another german mathematician but that
was like a hundred years later so it
seems that euler was way ahead of his
time you can get to the 12th in more
than one way that's right in more than
one way so earlier get to minus 1 over
12 in in a particular way
riemann explained later gave a rigorous
theory using his zeta function
a theory which involved things like
complex numbers so something which is uh
was not yet fully developed at the time
of earlier although a lot of this
already existed and earlier himself was
considering complex numbers but also
there are other ways we now know other
possible ways of thinking of of how to
isolate this finite part in this
infinite series earlier was motivated by
some questions and in the process he not
only studied such sums here's here's an
example what else he studied he also
studied things like
one
cubed
plus 2 cubed
plus
3 cubed plus 4 cubed that seems to
diverge even faster than this one right
because you're now taking the sum of
cubes
you see and so again within this context
of divergent series if you just approach
this the way you know we approach it uh
when we study um you know first year
calculus definitely this blows up
definitely divergent this is infinity is
infinite the answer is infinity period
there's no way around it but earlier
allowed himself to do some manipulation
with such series and came up with a
total it was a different answer which
which was uh i don't remember exactly
but i think it was one minus one one
over 120. i don't remember exactly i
think it was that that was the answer
he also you might ask why did i skip
squares
actually you can do that as well but the
answer is even more surprising you
actually get zero
within that scheme and so on so he was
actually studying all possible uh
integer powers uh uh powers by natural
numbers like here you know this you can
think of this as 1 to the first power 2
to the first power 3 to the first power
and so on here these are the squares the
cubes and you can do the fourth power
and so on and so the funny thing happens
is for all even values you actually get
zeros and for odd values you get some
rational numbers on the original videos
everyone got really upset and said you
cannot
do this with divergent series are you
saying you can and you're saying they
broke the rules and then you're saying
they did it what is the rules here
well the rules
it depends rules within which context
okay so let me ask you to illustrate
what i mean by this let me ask you a
question
does the square root of negative 1 exist
come on brady
well i know we call it i and we have
these imaginary numbers right
but does it really exist does it exist
does it make sense to speak of a square
root of negative one
one possible answer is absolutely not
right because if we think about real
numbers we know that the square of any
real numbers is positive
so the square root of a positive number
is well defined square root of 0 is also
well defined is 0 but there is no square
root of a negative number so we can stop
there and say square root of 1 a
negative one doesn't exist and anyone
who uses square root of negative one
is an outlaw
right and because that's not legitimate
uh this is some dirty tricks
but actually we now and and that's how
people viewed it for a while for a long
time but actually now we understand that
there is a rich
and consistent theory which includes the
square root of negative one that is the
theory of complex numbers and this
theory provides us with a much more
interesting much richer context much
more fruitful context in which in fact
we could solve a lot of problems about
real numbers so in other words we have
to go outside of the realm of real
numbers oftentimes to get the best uh
most optimal or sometimes the only
possible solutions
about real numbers so it is in that
sense that now no mathematician in their
sort of right mind would say the square
root of negative 1 does not exist yes it
exists in the sense that we can add it
to real numbers we obtain a well-defined
numerical system which is called complex
numbers which is just as legitimate as
the system of real numbers are you
saying that
manipulating a divergent series is in
the same category as that
well uh i would say that's a good
analogy because um
there is
it shows that sometimes there are
different contexts in which you can
discuss different things so in the case
of square root of negative one there's a
context of real numbers where square
root of negative one surely doesn't
exist
or there's a context of complex numbers
where it does exist and it's actually
very useful and likewise here there is
other obvious context of the you know
the rules of of analysis the rules of
calculus rules of infinite series in
which none of the series are well
defined and therefore all the
manipulations we do with such infinite
series are not well defined but then
there is another context in which we
replace the series by their sort of
regularized values and i really like to
think of this regularized values as sort
of like you know removing some of sort
of like there's a imagine like a piece
of gold which is surrounded by this
infinite amount of dirt and you kind of
throw away this dirt and you're left
with this little piece of gold so what
i'm trying to say is that each of this
infinite series contains inside it seems
this little piece of gold and then we
can say well that little piece of gold
is the value is the true value of that
infinite series and on the rest of it
it's kind of useless and can just throw
it away
if you say that and if and there is a
rigorous mathematical framework for
doing that then some of the
manipulations in fact all the
manipulations that earlier did
uh become legitimate because you what
you are doing is you are kind of
carrying with you those little those
sort of valuable pieces on each side of
the of the formula as well as those
infinite things and you kind of you can
throw the infinite things away and then
whatever relations you find between the
infinite series will also be the valid
relation between those valuable pieces
professor it seems very
my understanding of mathematics is it's
very rigid and rigorous and it's never
arbitrary how can you just throw away
dirt and keep the gold it doesn't seem
that's right well well in a way it is uh
it's a great question because i think
that it's a misconception to think of
mathematics as this sort of linear
process where
we are only doing things which are
legitimate which are allowed if we were
doing that we would never discover
square root of negative one we would
never even discover squared of two for a
long time people did not believe that
square root of two actually was a
legitimate number because it cannot be
expressed as a fraction
right it cannot express a fraction and
for a long time people thought the only
legitimate numbers were fractions
right so actually every once in a while
uh
there are people like leonard euler
like riemann and others who who actually
ramanujan is another example who kind of
jump into the abyss of the unknown and
break the rules and try to
to kind of push the veil over the
unknown and try to understand more and
sometimes they are actually doing
something maybe illegitimate at the time
maybe they're ahead of their time but
one thing which is important in
mathematics is that
we can never leave sort of these things
as loose ends we have to find a
justification so you're right
mathematics is rigorous and at the end
of the day we are looking for a rigorous
justification a rigorous explanation of
everything in other words we are not
content with just saying that there is
some magic over there there is magic but
we always want to explain it and that's
what has happened to some extent with
this series the work of riemann gave us
a tool to analyze the sort of
uh the golden parts of this infinite
series and uh but i still think that the
last word on the subject has not been
said because we still don't fully
understand at least i don't fully
understand why every time this such a
series pops up in mathematics or in
physics
um it we get the right result by
replacing it by precisely that value or
by this value for this one in physics
for example
um this kind of calculations are done
all the time and in fact maybe it is the
best kept secret maybe in physics in
quantum physics is that most of the
calculations that physicists do today
are like this that the answer they get
is infinite at the outset
on the face of it it looks infinite but
they find ways to assign meaningful
values to this infinity so to speak and
they and it is really
really i think it's a good analogy to
think about it is kind of like
surgically removing some kind of
infinite part which is
redundant and uh superfluous and
throwing it away and replacing the
answer with this finite remainder um and
the interesting thing is that in physics
physics are still kind of waiting for
their own women to come and sort of
and to justify these calculations but
they've been incredibly successful in
getting results which they can then test
experimentally and some of this has been
tested with an astonishing degree of
accuracy is it a sum is assigning the
value the same as the sum is that where
things have gone wrong is all where
things have become confused i would say
it's a it's not exactly the sum because
it's
the the exact sum as you see you know it
blows up it is infinite um it is a kind
of regularized sum but i am surprised
for example uh why why is it that every
time we encounter such a sum
uh in mathematics and there are so many
places where we do that where we do
encounter this kind of sums um every
time we encounter these sums we always
have this sort of um reactions like oh
we should replace it by minus 1 over 12.
and every time we do that
we get the right answer and then maybe
later on mathematicians find an
alternative way you know because you
know in mathematics you can often you
know there are different approaches the
different solutions so you have a
problem but you try to you can solve it
in many different ways so that's an
indication i think that if we come up
with such an infinite sum
it's an indication that maybe we're
doing something not quite right we're
kind of applying um maybe a kind of a
naive approach
but
interestingly every time it happens if
we replace it by minus 1 over 12 we get
the right result and then later on we
can justify and choose a different route
and and have a different explanation so
what does it mean does it mean that in
some sense
it is there is a context in which the
sum this infinity sum is mysteriously
minus 1 over 12. i'm not sure
it's clearly there is something in there
which we still don't fully understand
for now our understanding is that minus
1 over 12 is the sort of golden part is
this sort of finite part in this
in this infinite lump which you get by
throwing away some infinite dirt
i'm going to give you an astounding
result astounding an astounding result
so i'm going to write down a little sum
and we're just going to see what what
answer it gives 1 plus two plus three
plus four
plus